hallo mein name ist luca und viele leute
hassen mich deswegen habe ich mir mal
wieder 10 10 oder 11
oder vielleicht sogar zwölf ich habe auf
jeden fall ein paar kommentare
rausgesucht wo ich mir wieder dachte wow
da ist doch einfach nur fremdschämen pur
hält sich in new york habe ich dieses
bild gepostet wo ich so toll neben der
skyline stehe und sehe ich dich
hubschraubers darunter der kommentar von
robyn zj 123 da wäre ich jetzt gern
er wollte wahrscheinlich gern schreiben
aber sich dabei irgendwie verschrieben
denkt man sich natürlich erstmal so jo
kann passieren normaler
rechtschreibfehler kg sind jetzt auch
nicht so weit auseinander tastatur dann
kommt der leoni janet robin hood 13 kern
kern ein fucking ernst alter naja
vielleicht wenn man so ein beruhigungs
kurs ganz gut dann habe ich bei twitter
gepostet hört niemals auf euch selbst
übertreffen manche sagen acht stunden
schlaf ist genug warum nicht neun
erreichen wollen oder zehn darunter
schreibt kosten
du sprichst mir aus der seele du mist
geburt anzeige es raus gut ihm hat sich
auf dem empire state building war habe
ich das bild gepostet wo ich lache wie
sonne totalen mist herunterkamen ganz
coole kommentare wie beispielsweise
lucia oder lol oder saucool oder neiße
hose oder cooles bild oder omg wie süß
oder geil allerdings auch ein kommentar
von dem user will soll lies
ich will deine englisch note nicht
wissen auf diesem bild hier saß ich auf
der brooklyn bridge ja ich weiß dass
dort täglich trilliarden leute darüber
lauf und ich mich da einfach drauf
gesetzt habe ich kleiner ekel darunter
der kommentar von kag zwerg wieso riesen
nacktschnecke die ihre spur hinterlässt
liegt da wie eine missgeburt aber freuen
es wird noch schlimmer
leon ski schreibt darunter bist du in
berlin
ok dann war da noch eine sache runter
geschrieben und zwar von louis gehrmann
animiert hdf connys hammergeil wie viel
mühe er sich für seine videos geht sitzt
er drei stunden am pc und rendert videos
und ihr behandelt ihn wie ein stück
scheiße man besser behandelt
unter dem gleichen bild stand auch noch
der kommentar der luca hat einen kutter
und mit dem kutter fängt er butter
lernen deutsch [ __ ]
ich weiß habe ich darüber lachen soll
oder da ich das ist bättig hier seht ihr
ein luca der im flugzeug liegt und
gepennt hat währenddessen hat eine
stewardess mein handy genommen ein foto
von mir gemacht weil ich auch bei der
landung noch am kennen und ist auch
vollkommen egal mir ist gerade meine
objektiv blende runtergefallen das ist
definitiv nicht sogar gewesen darunter
erst mal ein kommentar von hdj
du fliegst mit lufthansa danke für die
informationen dann unter anderem auch
von definitiv nicht tor flugzeug penner
ok lucky star schreibt runter immer am
panel luca düffel kritiker darunter luca
die beauty-queen wieso wie inwiefern bin
ich eine beauty queen und installment
unterschreibt runter er wie oft kennst
du eigentlich am taktik tower pr
wieso sagt jeder dass ich die ganze zeit
am penn bin der eine schreibt du kennst
schon wieder der andere schreibt le pens
am ganzen tag wie lange kennst du
eigentlich ich bin noch nie das diesem
foto hier stand ich auf einem stein am
central park und das war ganz geil weil
das wetter war nicht so geil aber das
foto ganz gut mit den konturen und im
hintergrund man die skyline und ich mag
das foto eigentlich bett leon gary 13
machte das foto denke ich nicht so gern
denn er hat dort runter geschrieben und
bist du wenigstens ins wasser gefallen
nein bin ich mich
enttäuschen musste wie ihr seht ihr
einen coolen zählt wie von mir und dem
polizisten und da schreibt der gommer
hdtv darunter du bist der sheriff nein
bin ich mich und wie in gottes namen
hatte sheriff geschrieben wenn andere
kommentar darunter fand ich recht witzig
und zwar jay schreibt neben luca fest er
macht so cool höflichen tirols ihr seht
ihr ein unfassbarer geiles bild von mir
in einem schwimmreifen meine mimik sagt
alles so schrieb der story lp darunter
eine geschichte doppelpunkt es war
einmal ein kleiner kontrast er saß im
pool und trank das pipi wasser der
friede torpedo unterstrich schreibt m
ich will ja nicht sagen das hat kindes
sei aber das ist kindisch du kleiner
böser böser böser böser panel bürger
verstehe ich nicht wieso schreibt diesen
scheiß darunter das kann doch nicht sein
das letzte bild für heute und daneben
auch fertig mit der täglichen portion
dummheit das bin ich im auto im stau auf
der autobahn der titel unter diesem bild
war
[ __ ] my life im stau 35 grad et cetera
pp und schreibt der dummkopf darunter we
don't [ __ ] your life ihr dürft es nicht
so wörtlich nehmen was ich unter bilder
schreibe und dummkopf hd dein bild ist
schon sehr sehr geil ich hab mir gerade
beim klatschen gegen die lippen
das war es hier jetzt heute mit dem
video dumme kommentare instagram
peinlich blablabla wolle man ganz kurzes
ernstes wörtchen ihr wisst normalerweise
nämlich nicht immer auf den keks und
nämlich selber auf dem kieker und
beleidige mich selbst und ich finde es
auch nicht schlimm und alles und so
weiter aber versteht doch bitte dass ihr
nicht in die folge kommt wenn ihr
einfach einen total behinderten
kommentar schreibt wie beispielsweise
du missgeburt du [ __ ] ich [ __ ]
dein leben irgendwie sowas das ist nicht
cool ich weiß dadurch dass ich diese
serie mache machen das extra leute dass
die dumme kommentare schreiben oder was
weiss nicht aber ihr kompetitiv nicht in
die folge wenn ihr mich einfach grundlos
die ganze zeit beleidigt da werdet ihr
einfach nur blockiert ich so schon
selber sachen raus die meistens noch
etwas länger her sind und wo ich wusste
dass ich da noch nicht die serie gemacht
habe und so weiter und so fort
ich nehme euch nicht dran wenn ich mich
einfach grundlos beleidigt ich denke das
ist ganz gut jetzt immer gesagt wenn
euch das video gefahren und will ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen soll ich
das noch mal machen dann schreibe es in
die kommentare und wir sehen uns ist
vielleicht mal wieder wenn ich jetzt
nicht gleich vom stuhl fall und sterbe